we are less than 24 hours from election
day president trump and former vice
president joe biden will continue
to make their final appeals to voters in
campaign appearances today
face the nation moderator margaret
brennan has interviewed both candidates
and she joins us now good morning to you
margaret brennan
good morning to you gail so you know
both candidates i know you're on calls
with both campaigns last week and they
both say they feel very confident
i don't expect any candidate to say you
know it's not looking good for us i'm
very worried
but does any candidate in your opinion
have reason to feel more confident than
the others we stand here today 24 hours
out
well the democrats can look at those
banked votes that early vote and feel
good about the edge they have in certain
states but
as the head of the republican party
ronna mcdaniel told me i'm face the
nation yesterday
she feels that because they have sent
staff
door to door in key states asking
republicans hey why haven't you voted
yet
they believe there is a surge that we
haven't seen yet
that will show up in person tomorrow and
if you look at states like florida and
texas
republicans who are showing up to vote
early have chipped away
at some of the democratic lead in those
states but
president trump is really going to be
very heavily dependent on his supporters
showing up
in large numbers tomorrow and joe biden
is going to be heavily dependent on
those votes that are still out there
particularly
young voters that the biden campaign is
betting on
margaret the the president's closing
message appears to be
a return to normal return to a time
before the coronavirus and yet as he
makes that pitch to voters
in 13 battleground states cases of the
virus are surging
how do those two facts intersect in
effect election day
surging 45 percent over the past two
weeks in those 13
battleground states i mean at a certain
point tony you ask
how long will the president's supporters
allow him to deny the facts
in their own communities of spiking
infection rates and hospitalization
rates but to this point and many of the
present supporters that i've spoken to
when we do these voter focus groups tell
us
look it could have been worse and he's
doing the best he can there's an
acceptance somehow
but as this gets worse heading into the
winter you wonder when the facts will
overcome the
politics certainly for the biden
campaign they believe that their
strongest message
is to remind the public that the
president
didn't protect the american people
against a pandemic that has killed more
than 200 thousand people for the trump
campaign
they continue to argue don't believe the
headlines
even though in states like wisconsin
which are going to be so key for the
president
that spiking infection rate could have
an impact even on turnout tomorrow as
the governor
really warns people it's dangerous to go
out i know let's
let's hit on that don't believe the
headlines thing for just a second
margaret because now president trump
is saying that speculating out loud that
he may fire anthony fauci after the
election
this is after a campaign stop where
people were screaming in the crowd fire
fauci fire fauci
the president seems to be stoking that
fauci has made it very clear that this
is a very dangerous time he's telling us
all be careful with your thanksgiving
plans
what do you make of that well
at a certain point it becomes troubling
to hear yeah
deeply troubling to hear dr fauci
himself say in that interview he gave to
the washington post the bit that
that really struck me was when he flat
out
said that the president won't listen to
his briefings or dr burks anymore
because it doesn't fit the political
message so you have
the nation's top epidemiologists saying
the political uh folks don't want to
listen to the science and the facts
uh and so for for a doctor who says he
has no political agenda
uh that is obviously a warning to those
uh
out there that that they are at greater
risk than what they are being told so
the bottom line here and dr gottlieb
said this to us on face the nation
yesterday
at a certain point the facts are going
to overcome the politics the question is
when
he's saying it's going to be after the
election in thanks that thanksgiving
period then it is really going to hit us
hard and it's going to become
undeniable that we are not around the
curve in fact it's coming at us hard
and that's why margaret brand people are
feeling so stressed thank you very much